trust me I'm not jealous in the least it
bothers you and I used to [__] for money
yeah maybe if you had a little respect
for yourself would bother you too I just
I want to know that I'm not crazy
compounds called diethyl phenol
tryptamine this is America I don't know
what I'll do at this point I'm willing
to whatever it takes critically post
your video diaries daily I find myself
being able to see things a little more
clearly their relationships were being
torn apart by conflict crazy and you
tested it by giving drugs and made them
more possible certain have some concerns
about this drug be devious you can not
throw the word rape around unless you
were absolutely sure he held me down and
he [__] raped me I know for sure the
medicines working
I made you [__] shoot myself I can't
take this anymore this isn't gonna be
easy for me this comes in handy when
it's time to realign the mood due up
with a gun away please
you